there's a big divide that we're seeing
in this country right now and a lot of
people are waking up to the fact that
the divide is not
sexual as the left would tell us the
divide is not racial
as the left would tell us the divide is
not even partisan
i don't even think the divide is
republicans versus democrats in many way
what we've seen in the past few years is
that there's a kind of unit party
there's just this blob and there's it's
mostly run by democrats but there are a
few court jester republicans there whose
job it is to provide the appearance of
opposition but really they're just
they're just gestures they just really
exist to prop up that establishment and
do you know who showed this to us
nicki minaj nick i didn't see that one
coming okay i wouldn't have put my money
on that on that bet but she showed us
this she got into a fight
uh yesterday or two days ago with joy
reid joy reed is
ostensibly this left-wing woman on msnbc
and nicki minaj i think is left-wing
maybe not it's very unclear what her
politics are now nicki minaj comes out
and says look mask up follow some
guidelines but make your own healthcare
decisions don't don't take that shot and
think that there are no
concerns whatsoever and then she told
this story about a friend of hers who
had some health problems apparently from
from the vaccine and she says you know
just
do your own research make your own
decisions enjoy reid the
putative radical comes out and says no
don't do that don't do your own research
take the shot do what fauci says and
nicki minaj comes back to her and says
you're just a chill you're just a total
shill for the white man is what the
words of nicki minaj but i think what
she was implying is you're a show for
the establishment you're a shill for the
ruling class how you're telling people
they can't use their own minds so then
to make this situation even more
politically complicated
tucker carlson
on his
very conservative tv show came out and
defended nicki minaj
and nicki minaj
reposted that to her twitter account
with a bull's-eye take a listen to
tucker's monologue it's nicki minaj's
cousin's friend's testicles who are
swollen from taking the facts that's the
claim
but it's not anything to do with the
physical effect of the vaccine that
makes our political class mad it's the
last part of nicki minaj's tweet that
enrages them the part where she says you
should pray on it make the decision
yourself
like a free human being and quote don't
be bullied
so our media and public health officials
didn't like this because they make their
livings bullying people so they couldn't
let it stand
so
tucker gives as as always a terrific
little monologue and nicki minaj reposts
that with a bullseye emoji so you've now
got this major
pop star who
we all assumed was on the left
who is tweeting even about how she
doesn't like the white man that much and
how you know she's upset that a black
woman like joy reed would go along with
the white man who's not even usually a
white man but he's the ruling class and
then she's posting this
what we're told is this hetero
patriarchal you know
imperial hegemonic sort of tucker
carlson she's posting him and saying
that guy's got it exactly right and what
what is the criticism from everyone in
the ruling class on tucker
tucker is a populist tucker doesn't fit
neatly forget that he he disregards and
contradicts a leftist orthodoxy but he
doesn't even fit neatly on the right
he's not a usual republican he's
something different he's a terrible
white nationalist he's that's the phrase
they use now when they really want to
shut somebody up on the right
but what tucker is is he's just not
going to play along with the preset
ridiculous caricatures of our politics
of the last 20 years
which is there's supposed to be
the leftist
radical and then there's the right
winger who really he's just a
libertarian or something he just cares
about tax cuts and then there's kind of
the liberal ruling class and we see this
all play out and then nothing really
changes
and tucker comes in and he says no
no i don't think so i think it's it's
less about this pretend republican
democrat left right divide i think it's
more about the people versus the ruling
class and nicki minaj agrees i'm so glad
you liked that clip if you want to check
out the whole show which i would
strongly recommend go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play type in
the michael knowles show
subscribe leave us a five star review we
really appreciate it see you next time
[Music]